prime minister
a little more than 24 hours is taking
the top job Rishi sunak stood in the
House of Commons for the first time as
prime minister from the opposition labor
party and acknowledgment of the historic
moment may I welcome the Prime Minister
the first British Asian prime minister
is a significant moment in our national
story but there was a quick return to
Rody partisan politics and a call for an
early general election
working people have their say and call a
general election
from Rishi sunak an echo from his words
on Tuesday insisting his mandate was
clear
and we won and they lost
Elliot the new prime minister met his
leadership team for the first time but
he's already facing criticism for his
appointment of suela Braverman as Home
Secretary the UK's interior Minister she
was sacked Just A Week Ago by Liz truss
for a classified data breach an
appointment sunak was forced to defend
the Home Secretary made an error of
judgment but she recognized that she
raised the matter and she accepted her
mistake and that's why that's why I was
delighted to welcome back into a United
cabinet that brings experience foreign
Ty to the heart of government Rishi
sunak was propelled into the job after
list trust presided over an economic
meltdown in her first few weeks in
charge now the announcement of how the
government Will Repair the country's
finances has been delayed by the change
at the top it's also extremely important
that that statement is based on the most
accurate possible economic forecasts and
forecasts of public finances and for
that reason the Prime Minister and I
have decided that it is prudent to make
that statement on the 17th of November
as Prime ministerial debuts go this was
perhaps as good as Rishi sunai could
hope but the issues facing Liz trust
haven't disappeared complete questions
and there will be tougher days ahead
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Westminster